"I want to continue in Volume 3, beginning with December 27, 1899. And this is about love.
Jesus continued to make himself seen like a shadow and a flash. While I was in a sea
of bitterness," Louisa said, "because of his absence, in one instant he made himself
seen, telling me that charity," now when Jesus uses the word charity, unfortunately
our modern life has destroyed that word and even evil people can be running
charities. So we have to be careful that this is divine love, it's agape in Greek,
okay, and it's the greatest of the theological virtues. Charity must be
like a mantle, which must cover all of your actions in such a way that everything
must shine with perfect love. So I want to give you one Corinthians 14, one, you
must want love more than anything else. I want to give you one John 4, seven, God
is love. I want to give you Colossians 3, 14, and there is so much else in the New
Testament about love. I've already given you many references. So Jesus says that
love must cover absolutely everything we do, otherwise in his eyes it has no
value because God is love. What is the meaning of your being displeased when you
do not suffer? He said to her, "That means that your charity or your love is
not perfect because suffering for love of me and not suffering for love of me
without your will is all the same." Now what he's saying is suffering isn't the
issue. Loving God is. And if you suffer for love of God when the will of God
requires it, or when you are without suffering for the love of God when the
will of God requires it, it is the will of God and love that matters. I've said to
you before a number of times that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine
will and love. Then he disappeared. Louisa said, "Leaving me more and bitter than
before, wanting to touch a key too delicate for me. That's her whole desire
for suffering which he himself had infused in me. Then after I shed bitter
tears for my miserable state and over the absence of my adorable Jesus he came
back and he told me with just souls I act with justice or rather I give them
double recompense for their justice by favoring them with grace or graces." And
I would refer you there to the book of Daniel chapter 13. I speak to them he
said of just words and of holiness. So Louisa has offered herself as a victim
to divine justice so it might be good to remind yourself of this and write it
down on the page and so she is being dealt with according to justice because
she has committed herself to divine justice. But divine justice is holy, is
wise, is merciful, is loving, is everything because it's God. So Louisa
said, "I found myself so confused and bad that I didn't dare to offer a single
word. Rather I continued to shed tears over my misery." And Jesus wanting to
infuse trust in me placed his hand under my head in order to lift it because it
couldn't hold itself up and he added, "Do not fear I am the shield of those who are
troubled." Okay and he disappeared. So the Lord's shield or protection I want to
give you Genesis 15 1. I want to give you Sam 3 verse 3 and Sam 5 verse 12. Sam 28
verse 7, Sam 33 verse 20 and so on. There are loads of examples, "I am your shield,
I am your encircling shield," the Lord said to Abraham in Genesis 15. So we come
to December the 30th 1899 where the subject is mortification, a subject we
don't particularly like. Louisa said, "This morning I saw my adorable Jesus for
just a little and since obedience had told me to pray for a certain person, when
Jesus came I commended her to him and he said to me, "Humiliation must not only be
accepted but also loved, so much so that you would chew it like food." Now most of
us don't think in terms of humiliation as something you would choose or want or
thank God for. But in actual fact he's saying that we should accept it and love
it and resign ourselves to it for the simple reason that humiliation helps us
to get into that place of nothingness which is the safest place on planet
earth. And just as he said when a food is bitter, the more one chews it, the
more one feels the bitterness in the same way humiliation when it is well chewed
gives rise to mortification. In other words you'll put the self aside as you
should. And these, that is humiliation and mortification, are the two most
powerful means in order to get out of certain hitches. In other words sticky
wickets that we get ourselves into. Jesus says humiliation and mortification is
the way out to obtain those graces which are actually needed. So I want to give
you Proverbs 18, 12 and Proverbs 22, 4 and I want to give you Sam 113 verses 7 to
9. So Jesus continues while it seems to be
donxious to human nature just like the bitter food which seems to do harm rather
than good, so with humility and mortification but it is not so. The more
the piece of iron is beaten on the anvil, the more it sparkles with fire and
is purged and it is the same for the soul. So the humiliation and the
mortification is the same as the fire on the iron. The more she is humiliated and
beaten on the anvil of mortification the more she sparkles with celestial fire
and is purged. In other words the huge internal spiritual and mental and
emotional and physical purity that is required for us to walk with God and be
in union with Him can only be acquired this way. So if she really wants to walk
along the path of good that's the way it goes but if she wants if she's false
it's all the opposite. So I want to give you 1 Peter 5 5 Colossians 2 18 and Luke
1814. So now I want to go to January the first 1900 beginning the most evil and
violent century in history as Jesus himself tells us and Louisa is
considering the circumcision of Jesus. Being very afflicted because of the
privation of my highest and only good. After much waiting and waiting finally I
saw him coming out from within my heart. You see he's there all the time but she's
demanding to see him externally. He was crying and making me understand with
his eyes that he was hurting from the wound received in the circumcision. So he
cried and he expected me to dry the blood that was pouring from that wound.
Don't forget this is happening on a spiritual level this isn't happening on
an earthly physical level. He expected me to dry the blood pouring from that
wound and to sweeten the pain of the cut. I felt all compassion and also
confusion together so much so that I didn't dare do it. However drawn by love
I don't know how I found a little cloth in my hand and I tried as much as I could
to dry the blood of baby Jesus. While doing this I felt all full of sin because
you see the creature is touching the holy one and I thought that I was the
cause of the pain of Jesus. Oh how sorry I felt for him. I felt absorbed in that
bitterness and the blessed little baby sympathizing with my miserable state told
me the more the soul humbles herself and knows herself the closer she draws to
the truth. And being in the truth she tries to push herself along the path of
virtues from which she sees herself far away. Now let's go back a little bit why
would Jesus ask her and in this out of the body experience to do the action that
his mother would have done after the circumcision which is to tend to the
circumcision wound. You've got to remember that back in Volume 2 Jesus had asked
Louisa to be another mother for him on the earth and so this is an image of the
church bleeding and that in all of Louisa's prayers and intercessions and her
sufferings that she's an actual fact tending to the wounds of the church. And
in the whole process Louisa becomes more and more and more aware of her own
sinfulness. Now don't forget this woman is at a very high degree of union with
God. She's had three spiritual marriages that nobody else has ever had but you
see it's the people who see God can see the desperate
filtiness of human nature the rest of us can't see anything because we're just
so wrapped up in it and we've never seen God. So Jesus says the more the soul
humiliates herself and knows herself that you truly know and acknowledge your
own difficulties and problems. The closer she draws to the truth well Jesus is
the truth John 14 6 and being in the truth she tries to push
herself along the virtues and she sees herself pretty far from them. So that's
Isaiah 43 19 and if she sees herself on the path of virtues immediately she
realizes how much there is left for her to do because virtues have no end because
they're infinite just as I am and so being in the truth the soul always tries
to perfect herself. There's a lovely passage in Philippians chapter 3 where
Paul says I haven't completed the race I haven't reached the end but I'm racing
for the prize for which Christ Jesus captured me. In other words I keep my head
towards the destination and that's all I'm looking at and I'm putting all my
energy into that. That's what Jesus is telling Louisa here. So being in the truth
the soul always tries to perfect herself but she will never arrive at seeing
herself perfect. Ephesians 6 4, 1 Corinthians 5 8, 2 Corinthians 4 2 and 2
Corinthians 6 7. I could give you more but that's enough. And Jesus said because
she sees that she will never arrive at being perfect this serves her and it
will make her work continuously striving to perfect herself more without wasting
time in idleness. Now the people who think they're doing grand are sitting back
doing nothing about going forward and the problem is that in the spiritual life
you're either in reverse gear or you're moving forward. You're not you're not
actually sitting on a platform. And Jesus said and when I'm pleased with this
work I keep retouching her little by little. That's Ephesians 2 10 we are
God's work of art created in Christ Jesus. Philippians 1 6 Jesus says the
work I have begun in you I will finish. Okay and the whole idea is to produce the
likeness of Jesus in us. That's Romans 8 29. We will be conformed to the image of
the Son. So this is why I wanted to be circumcised. He said to give an example
of the highest humility which rendered the very angels of heaven stunned because
after all Jesus was God. He wasn't just a man. So January the third 1900 is about
peace. And I want to give you Luke 1 79 Luke 2 14 Jesus is the Prince of Peace.
John 14 27 John 16 33 Ephesians 2 16 that where Paul tells us that Jesus is
our peace. So Louisa says I continue to see myself full of miseries not only so
but also I was restless. It seems to me that all of my interior had become
alarmed at the loss of Jesus. I kept thinking to myself that my great sins
had made me deserve that my adorable Jesus had left me and therefore I was
not going to see him anymore. So there you have the lament of Sam 63 oh God you
are my God for you I long for you my soul is thirsting and so on. What a cruel
death this thought is for me or rather more ruthless than death no longer to
see Jesus no longer to hear the gentleness of his voice to lose the one on whom my
life depends. Now she actually means that physically physically as well as
spiritually because she's living a non-natural life sitting in a bed doing
nothing to keep her body alive and healthy. So Jesus has to sustain her
life miraculously and from whom every good comes. How can I live without him?
Everything is over for me if I lose Jesus. Now Louisa has reached that stage of
Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10 that you love the Lord with all your heart all your soul
all your mind and all your being. So if he's not there as far as she's concerned
she's in hell. With these thoughts I felt the agony of death she said all of my
interior was upset for I wanted Jesus. Sam 42 I have nothing but tears for my
bread night and day as they say to me all day long where is your God? And Jesus in
a flash of light now God is light that's one John one five manifested himself to
my soul and of course John 8 as well I forget the verse right now and John 9 3
to 5 I am the light of the world Jesus said. So Jesus in a flash of light
manifested himself to my soul saying to me peace do not want to disturb
yourself so that means don't put your will into it. God is concerned very much
with what our wills agree to you may be feeling a bit upset but don't agree to
it don't wallow in it. Don't disturb yourself don't let that happen take
control. Just as the most fragrant flower perfumes the place in which it is
put so does my peace fill with God the soul who possesses it. That's Philippians 4
7 the peace that passes all understanding and guards the heart and the mind in
Christ Jesus. So Louisa said all Lord how good you are to this sinner and I also
tell you in confidence how the word in my book says impertinent which cannot be
the translation because it's a very negative offending word she says how
demanding you are for I must lose you lose you no less and you do not even want
me to become disturbed or restless and if I do it you make me understand that I
myself move away from you because the peace I feel I feel myself sorry because
with peace I fill myself with God while by becoming disturbed I fill myself with
diabolical temptations. There is Louisa learning a hard lesson that the rest of
us need to learn as well. If you allow disturbance inside of yourself and
negativity you're opening the door wide to the tempter to come in and wreck all
kinds of havoc in your soul. If you close the door to all that disturbance and all
that negativity and only allow the peace of God to rain in your heart then the
Lord can rain there because he is a God of peace and he cannot come in the middle
of a hurricane. And Louisa said my Jesus how much patience it takes with you she's
trying to learn how to respond to all of these challenges because whatever
happens to me I cannot even become upset or disturbed. And you see she has been
told that under no circumstances must must she disobey so she feels this
tremendous pressure coming on her to obey in an area that she finds extremely
difficult. So January the 5th 1900 we're talking about sin and confession. Again
you see this is only volume three we're dealing with fundamentals. Louisa said
as I was in my usual state I felt I was going outside of myself in and out of
the body experience and I found my adorable Jesus but oh how full of sins I
saw myself in his presence. You see the more we see God in his reality in his
essence the more we see ourselves and the less we see him the less we see
ourselves and that's why people in an early stage can really think that they're
doing well when an actual fact they're full of filth. In my interior Louisa
said I felt a strong desire to make my confession to our Lord and so turning to
him I began to tell him my sins and Jesus was listening to me. When I
finished speaking turning to me with the face full of sadness he told me my
daughter sin is a poisonous and deadly embrace to the soul Romans 7 verses 14 to
25. Now deadly means mortal it actually can kill. If the sin is grave and not
only to her but also to all the virtues present in the soul does it give this
deadly embrace that's why we call it mortal sin. If then the sin is venial it
is a wounding embrace which renders the soul very weak and
infirm and together with her the virtues that she had acquired they also become
weak and infirm. What a deadly weapon sin is. Sin alone can wound and give death
to the soul Romans 8 31 to 39. Nothing else can harm her nothing else but sin
alone renders her appropriatous and odious before me a translate that word
for you disgusting. So there's an awful lot of scriptures dealing with sin
because the whole of scripture is dealing with the battle between the
human will and the divine will. So I want to give you Sam 78 verses 19 to 21 and
verses 56 to 59. I want to give you John 3 36 Romans 1 18 in fact the whole of
chapter 1 of Romans Sam 5 5 Proverbs 6 verses 16 to 19. Isaiah 3
verses 11 to 26 to Corinthians 5 10. Revelation 20 12. Now while Jesus was
saying this I understood Louisa said the ugliness of sin and I felt such pain
that I cannot even express it and Jesus seeing me all contrite raised his
blessed hand and pronounce the words of the absolution. Then he added just as sin
wounds and gives death to the soul so does the sacrament of confession give
life so does it heal the wounds and give back vigor to the virtues and this more
or less according to the dispositions of the soul so does the virtue of the
sacrament operate. So there we being told that the sacrament operates at
whatever level that we're open to it. In other words if we've no intention of
amending our lives nothing's going to happen. Louisa said it seemed to me that
my soul had received new life. I no longer felt the bother as before and
Jesus gave me the when Jesus gave me the absolution. May the Lord be
always thanked and glorified. So January the 6th 1900 after sin and
confession we need to restore our confidence in God so that's the subject
here and we're told that confidence is the stairway to heaven. St. Therese of
this you said you will receive from God just what you have confidence for. If
you've no confidence in him you don't stimulate him to give you anything but
think of an ordinary family. If a child asks a parent for something but has no
trust or in the love of the parent and has no confidence that it can receive it
it gives no stimulus whatsoever to the parent to actually give the thing. This
morning I received communion Louisa said and I found myself together with Jesus
and the Queen mother was there as well. On marvel I looked at the mother and I
could see her heart transmuted into the baby Jesus. I looked at the son and I
could see the mother in the heart of the baby. In the meantime I remembered that
today is the epiphany and in the example of the holy magi I was to offer
something to the baby Jesus but I saw myself as having nothing to give him. So
in seeing my misery the thought came to me of offering my body as mirror with all
the sufferings of the 12 years in which I had been in bed ready to suffer and to
remain there as much longer as he pleased. That's a very important statement
because she's always longing to go to heaven. As gold I would offer him the
pain I feel when he deprives me of his presence which is the most painful and
sorrowful thing for me and as incense I would offer him my poor prayers united
to those of our Queen mother so that they might be more pleasing to the baby
Jesus and so I made the offering with full confidence that the baby would
accept everything. So I want to give you one Timothy for 10. I want to give you Sam 511, 1777,
62 8 and 118 verse 8. Jesus seemed to accept my poor offerings Louisa said but
that which he enjoyed the most was the confidence with which I offered them.
Then he said to me confidence has two arms, with one it embraces my humanity and it
uses my humanity as a staircase in order to ascend to the divinity. Now that's
John chapter 1 from verse 51 Jesus said that he was the fulfillment of the vision
of Jacob where he saw a stairway to heaven with the angels of God ascending
and descending. So first of all use the humanity of Jesus as a staircase in
order to ascend to his divinity. With the other one it embraces the divinity
and draws celestial graces in torrents. Now I have Luke 11 verses 9 to 10 there
in such a way that the soul remains all inundated with the divine being. That
means you have the humility and the confidence both together enabling you
to open up completely to what the blessed Trinity wants to do and so you
become all inundated with the divine being. When the soul is confident she is
certain to obtain what she asks. I let my arms be bound I let her do whatever she
wants I let her penetrate even into my heart and I let her take by herself that
what she has asked of me. So I want to give you Mark chapter 9 verse 24 and
Matthew 21 22. Everything is possible for one who believes. If I didn't do that he
said I would feel myself in a state of violence. While he was saying this many
rivelets of liquor and then in brackets Louisa said I call it liquor but I can't
really tell what it is. Came out from the breast of the baby and of the mother
which inundated my soul completely and then the Queen mother disappeared. After
this together with the baby I went out into the vault of the heavens. It's
wonderful when you're an out-of-the-body experience you can go anywhere but of
course these out-of-the-body experiences are very important for Louisa because
it's the balance to her being trapped in bed all the time. I saw that Jesus's
gracious face was sad and I said to myself maybe he wants milk this is why
he's sad so I said to him do you want to suckle from me since your holy mother is
not here. And before doing this I became concerned that it might be the devil
in other words she has to check out her discernment again. In order to be assured
I signed him several times with the cross and I said to him are you really
Jesus of Nazareth the Nazarene the second person of the most holy Trinity the
son of the Virgin Mary mother of God and the baby assured me that he was.
Therefore being assured I placed him to suckle from myself. The baby seemed to
revive assuming a merry appearance and I saw that he was suckling part of those
rivelets with which he himself had inundated me. This is terribly important
we've nothing to give to God we can only give back to him what he has given to
us. And while he was doing this I felt my heart being pulled out therefore don't
look at this in a very physical way this is a spiritual experience and heart
means your whole person your whole being. And it seemed that that milk which Jesus
was drawing from me was coming from the heart. Who can say what passed between me
and the baby Jesus I've no tongue to be able to manifest it no words to be able
to describe it. But I want to give you John 14 6 because Jesus is the source of
life and Colossians 1 16 as well. Now January the 8th 1900 we're talking about
Louisa's writings. I was thinking to myself Louisa said who knows how much
nonsense how many errors are contained in these writings that I write. At that
moment I felt I was losing consciousness that means going into ecstasy and blessed
Jesus came and said to me my daughter errors too will do good. And this in
order to make known that there's no artifice on your part and that you're
not some doctor that means a doctor of theology or scripture because if you
were so you yourself would realize where you were mistaken. This will also make
shine more that it is I who speak to you. Now this is only volume three and in the
higher volumes up in the volumes over volume 20 Jesus actually says that
every single part of the message that is given in Louisa's writings is from
himself. And it had to be from him. Louisa had no education. So it will also
point out that was I myself that spoke to you by looking at it in a simple way
however I assure you that they will not find a shadow of vice or anything which
is not virtue because while you write I myself guide your hand that's extremely
important. And another mystic still alive Vasulu Reden also has that
experience that the Lord actually guides her hand. So I want to give you
Deuteronomy 32 15 the Lord alone with her guide. Having said this Jesus
disappeared and after a few hours he came back I was feeling all hesitant and
concerned about the words he had spoken to me and he added. My heritage is
firmness and stability. Now another word that he uses all the time is
immutability. You cannot change God. You cannot change his word. You cannot
change his laws. Nothing they are immutable there as we would say carved in
stone. And the problem with the society like ours that has moved away into
immorality and into rebellion against God they think they can change God's laws
to suit the lower level that they're at. But you can't do that. God's law doesn't
change. Nothing about God changes. He's the same yesterday today and forever. My
heritage he says is firmness and stability and the more we walk with God
the more we absorb him and move with him the more firm and stable we become as
well. I am not subject to any change he says and the more the soul draws near me
and advances on the path of holiness the firmer and more stable she feels in
doing good. The word here says always says operating we say doing. And the
further she remains away from me the more she will be subject to changing and
oscillating. Remember Jesus said about John the Baptist that he was not a read
blowing in the wind. Now a read blowing in the wind is someone oscillating and
moving and as people say nowadays going with the flow. So January 12th 1900 is a
very important section talking about knowledge of self. So finding myself in
my usual state Louisa said my adorable Jesus came in a pitiful state. He had
his hands bound tightly his face covered with spit and many people were
slapping him horribly and he remained quiet plastered without making one
movement that's Isaiah 53 7. He did not emit even one lament not even the
batting of eyelashes in order to show that he himself wanted to suffer these
outrages. So I want to give you Hebrews 12 to that for the joy that was set
before him he endured the cross despising the shame and I want to give you Mark
1441. And this was not just the case externally Louisa said but also
internally because the great insight that one of the great insights that Jesus
gave to Louisa was the revelation of the internal passion that nobody knew
about. What a moving scene such as to break the hardest hearts. How many things
that face said with that spit hanging dirtied with mud I felt horrified I
trembled I saw myself all full of pride before Jesus. I mean to think that our
God would suffer that for us would certainly horrify us. But while he was
in that appearance he said to me my daughter only the little ones let
themselves be handled as one wants. That's Matthew 18 verses 1 to 3 where
Jesus said to the apostles that he wanted them to become like little children.
And here he was showing the humility and simplicity of a child. Not those who are
little of human reason but those who are little yet filled with divine reason.
Now the littleness is the humility and it is a divine wisdom that would make
you respond like this. I alone can say that I am humble because in man that which
is said to be humility should rather be called knowledge of self. In other words
we stop blowing our trumpets when we realize that this is what I'm like and
that's what I'm like and this is what I do and that's what I do. The one who does
not know himself already walks in falsehood Jesus said. Jesus remains
silent for a few minutes and I stayed there contemplating him. While I was doing
this I saw a hand carrying a light which searching in my interior in the most
intimate hiding places wanted to see whether the knowledge of myself the love
of humiliations, confusions and the programs were present in me to Corinthian
6 3 to 10. That light found a void in my interior and I saw it as well which had
to be filled with humiliations and confusions according to the example of
Jesus. In other words she wasn't perfectly like him. Oh how many things
that light and that holy face which was before me made me understand. I said to
myself a God humiliated and confused for love of me and I a sinner without these
insignia. A God stable firm in bearing so many insults to the point that he
doesn't move not one bit to shake that disgusting spit off himself. His interior
before God and his exterior before men were made manifest to me and yet if he
wanted to free himself he could have done it because it is not the chains that
bind him but his firm will which wants to save the human race at any cost. And
what about me? Where are my humiliations? Where is the firmness and the constancy
in doing good for love of Jesus and love of my neighbor? How different we are as
victims myself and Jesus Louisa said we're not similar at all. Now we do you good
at this particular point to read the book of Sidak or Ecclesiastes chapter 2
and it explains the mystery of the humiliations. My son if you desire to
serve the Lord prepare yourself for a ordeal because gold is tested in the
fire and chosen people tested in the furnace of humiliation. I'll let you
read it. It's a most wonderful wonderful wonderful passage. So Louisa says while
my little brain was wandering in all of this my adorable Jesus said only my
humanity such to be a capital M was filled with the programs and humiliations
to the point that they overflowed outside. This is why heaven and earth
tremble before my virtues and the souls who love me use my humanity as a
staircase in order to ascend and to lap up a few little drops of my virtues. Now
the staircase is John 1 51 and Genesis 28 where Jacob saw the vision. Tell me now
before my humility Jesus says where is yours? And of course the answer is no
where Lord. I mean by comparison with you we were millions of miles away from the
starting point. I alone can glory in possessing true humility Jesus said. My
divinity united with my humanity could operate prejudice at each step each word
and each work and yet I voluntarily you see that's what he's saying that his
self-denial and his mortification and his humiliations and everything and his
passion it was voluntary and that is the thing that he's trying to say to us that
you know where is our voluntary gift to the Lord? He says I voluntarily
constrained myself within the circle of my humanity and I showed myself as the
poorest and I reached the point of mingling with sinners themselves. Okay? He
was called a friend of sinners wasn't he? You find that in Luke's gospel and I
give you Matthew 11 19 as well. I could have done the work of redemption in very
little time and even with one single word in other words he could have commanded
it from heaven but we would never have seen him as the love that he is. Yet
during the whole course of many years with many hardships and sufferings I
wanted to make the miseries of man my own. I wanted to exercise myself in many
different actions so that man might be completely renewed and divinized even
in the lowest works. This is where Jesus made a divine version of each one of us
because he sanctified he redeemed and sanctified every second of our lives
from conception to death and he suffered all our pains all our difficulties and
he redeemed them and he left us the grace and the strength to be able to
operate and let him work with us. So he said he completely renewed and
divinized even the lowest works for us. In fact once they had been exercised by
me who was God and man they received new splendor and remained with the mark of
divine works. You see he was able to elevate absolutely everything to a
divine level because being God the divine will was nature to him. My
divinity hidden within my humanity just like the presence of Jesus is hidden
inside of the bread and wine that's consecrated at mass. wanted to lower
itself to such baseness, subjecting itself to the course of human actions.
Now this is inconceivable to us because as human beings we all want to be
raised up and we want to be honored, we want to be recognized and we want to
be loved and all the rest of it. So to have him lower himself from a divine
level to the baseness that he actually did subjecting himself to the course of
human actions while with one single act of my will I could have created infinite
worlds. You see we have no idea how big God is. Feeling the miseries and the
weaknesses of others as if it were his own. So there's no way we can say to the
Lord you don't understand. You don't understand our struggles he does. Seeing
itself covered with all the sins of men before divine justice having to pay
their penalty at the price of unheard of pains and with the shedding of all
blood. Now that's Philippians chapter 2 verses 6 to 11 that his state was divine.
He did not cling to his equality with God but he became one of us and as one of
us he was humbler still accepting death even death on a cross.
Thus Jesus said that his he in his humanity exercised continuous acts of
profound and heroic humility. Now there is the model for us profound and heroic
humility and you find that in the letter Paul's letters to the Philippians chapter
2 at the very beginning of it I've just given you verses 6 to 11 so this is
verses 1 to 5 in which Paul says that we have to have the same mind the same way
of thinking as Christ Jesus. And then Jesus continued daughter here is the
immense difference between my humility and the humility of the rest of you even
that of all the saints no matter how great their humility was it was nothing
by comparison with his which is only a shadow he said in the face of mine because
the human creature is always a creature in other words completely limited and
small and nothing and does not know as I know in other words cannot grasp or
understand as I know how great is the weight of sin. That's our big problem
that today people don't even know that sin exists they seem to think that sin
has been abolished and because of that an enormous amount of sin is being
committed therefore the passion of Jesus is continuing in our society today.
Even though heroic souls following my example have offered themselves to
suffer the pains of others their pains are not different
they're not different from those of the other people they're not new things
for them because they're made of the same clay so if I want to suffer your
headache it's the same headache that you have
the same value moreover the mere thought that the pains
are the cause of new gains for them and that they glorify God is an honor for
them that's your Hebrews 12 too furthermore the creature or the human soul
is restricted within the circle in which God placed her
and she cannot go out of those limits
and she had oh yeah she can't go out of those limits
which are prescribed by God or if it were in their power to do
or undo things this is very important I think
and particularly to undo things how many other things
they would do how often we would said if we've all said if only I had a chance
to do that again I would do it very differently
everyone would reach the stars he said if they could all undo things
but my divinized humanity no notice the way he's expressing it
had no limits isn't that fantastic and yet it voluntarily
constrained itself within itself and this was the braiding of all my works
with heroic humility wow isn't that something else
I think that this is a text that you have to just read over and over and over
again and what will happen is we might grow a little bit in humility
ourselves and grow in love for Jesus
so Jesus continues this had been the cause of all evils
which inundate the earth this lack of humility
in other words pride and I need to give you Isaiah chapter two again
and it's verses seven nine and eleven that the pride of man must be brought
low if anything's going to happen on the earth
and so and by exercising this virtue I was to draw
all goods noticed by exercising this virtue I was to draw
all goods from divine justice aren't we being told something
that by being humble and little and throwing ourselves into our nothingness
that that's where the Lord will respond to us
ah yes he said no concessions of graces
come from my throne if not by means of humility
there it is clear as daylight Luke 1 51 he pulls the mighty from their
thrones and raises the lowly 1 Peter 5 5 to 9 and we have to bow
before the throne of God
so let's say it again ah yes no concessions of grace
come from my throne if not by means of humility
nor can any ticket be received by me if it does not carry the signature of
humility oops no prayer is listened to by my ears
and moves my heart to compassion if it is not perfumed by the fragrance
of humility
if the soul does not arrive at destroying that seed of honor that self-esteem
and this can be destroyed by arriving at
and loving loving to be despised humiliated and confused
she will feel a braiding of thorns around her
and she will feel avoid in her heart which will always bother her
and will render her very dissimilar
from my most holy humanity if she does not arrive at loving humiliations
at the most she will be able to know herself a little bit
but will not shine before me clothing clothed with the garment of humility
beautiful and worthy of sympathy now my dear friends
i can't comment on that the only thing i can do is fall
before on my face before the lord and adore and worship
and ask him to transform me i think it's absolutely incredible but he's
telling us if your prayers are not being heard
heard look and see where the humility is if your works have no value in his eyes
look and see where the humility is if your relationships are not working out
look and see where the humility is
louisa says who can say how many things i understood about this virtue
and the difference between knowledge of self and humility
uh i think that's the very important thing because we think we're humble
when we just know something about ourselves
i seem to touch with my own hand the distinction
between these two virtues but i have no words to explain myself
but in order to say something i will use an image he's going to try and talk
about self-knowledge for example a poor man says he's poor
and he honestly manifests his poverty also to people who do not know him
and who may believe that he possesses something
one can say that he knows himself and he tells the truth
and because of this he's loved more he moves others to compassion for his
miserable state and everybody helps him that's what it is to know yourself
if then feeling ashamed of manifesting his poverty that poor man boasted of
being rich while everyone knows that he doesn't even have
clothes to cover himself and that he's dying of starvation what would happen
then everyone despises him because he's lying
nobody helps him and he becomes an object of mockery and ridicule to anyone who
knows him and the miserable one going from bad to worse ends up dying
that is the way pride is before god and also before men
and here is how one who does not know himself already
leaves the truth and slumps into the path of falsehood
so i want to give you proverbs 8 13 and proverbs 11
2 and proverbs 16 18 i want to give you the book of Tobias
chapter 4 verse 13 and the book of Sirak chapter 10
verses 7 and 12
now here is the difference with humility
though it seems to me that knowledge of self and humility
are sisters born of the same womb and one can never be humble if he doesn't
know himself for example there is the rich man
who out of love of humiliation stripping himself of his noble garments
covers himself with miserable rags he lives on known manifesting to no one
who he is he mingles with the poorest he lives with the poor as if he was
one of them and makes scorns and confusions his delight
here is the beautiful sister of the knowledge of self
which is humility
so i want to give you Luke 19 verses 1 to 10
so now we're going to get one of Louise's lovely lists
humility draws grace is number one number two humility breaks
the strongest chains which are sin number three humility surmounts any wall
of division between the soul and god which brings her back to him
number four humility is a little plant but always green and flowery
not subject being gnawed by worms nor will winds hail and heat be able to do
harm to it nor make it with her even slightly
so number five though being the littlest plant
humility produces very high branches which penetrates even into heaven
braiding around the heart of the lord luisa loves the word braiding because
she was a lace maker
and only the branches which come from this plant have free access
to his adorable heart so number six humility is the
anchor of peace during the storms of the sea waves
of this life number seven humility is the salt
which spices all virtues and preserves the soul from the corruption of sin
number eight humility is the little grass which sprouts along by
which sprouts along the way but treaded on by wayfarers
while being treaded it disappears but soon one can see its sprout again more
beautiful than before so number nine humility is like
the gentle graft which renders a wild plant
gentle number 10 humility is the sunset of guilt
oh is no wonderful number 11 humility is the newborn
of grace number 12 humility is like the moon
which guides us in the darkness of the night of this life
number 13 humility is like that shrewd merchant
who knows well how to trade his riches and waste not even one cent of the grace
that is given to him number 14 humility is the key to the door
of heaven wow so there's one of your keys
and humility is the key to the door of heaven
such that no one can enter it into it if he does not keep this key in good
custody finally number 15 otherwise i would never end
and i would be too long humility is the smile of god
and of all heaven and it is the crying of all hell
because nobody gets into heaven without it
and nobody in hell has anything else but pride
humility knows nothing about hell and hell knows nothing about humility
so okay let's go on to january 17 1900
uh so in 1900 now we have moved into the 20th century
which is the century of deception the first horseman of the apocalypse
and in later volumes Jesus tells us that and also with other mystics
Jesus tells us that it was the most evil and violent
of all centuries of human history so for the evil and shrewdness of man i want
to give you Luke 16 verses 1 to 8 and i want to give you a
Matthew 23 and Revelation 6 verses 1 to 2 the first horseman of the apocalypse
this morning my adorable Jesus was coming and going but always in silence
so that means he's doing chastisements then i felt i was going outside of myself
and i felt Jesus behind me saying man says there is no more
rectitude and as long as things are this way
we will not be able to obtain any success in our intense
so let us fake virtue you see it's it's the century of deception
and the 20th century was the thing that gave us plastic
you know so i can wear this beautiful string of pearls around my neck
but they're not real they're not real pearls
and unfortunately those plastic virtues as well pretense
horror let us fake virtue let us pretend we are upright
let us show ourselves as true friends on the outside
for in this way it will be easier to weave our nets and deceive others
oh dear so i want to give you a Matthew 23 for this
and when we come out to plunder them and harm them
since everyone believes that we are friends we will easily have them in our
hands without resistance and Jesus said look at where the
shrewdness of man actually reaches now
January 1900 you have atheistic Marxism or Marxist atheism
being spread out into the whole world you're going to do
absolutely horrendous damage you have communism that pretended to be
friends and pretended to do good but in actual fact
it was utterly destructive so louisa said after this wanting a special
act of reparation blessed Jesus seemed to cut my life off
offering me to divine justice in the act in which he was doing this i thought
that Jesus would make me pass away from this life
and so i said to him lord i don't want to come to heaven without your insignia
this is the only time she ever stopped him from taking her
all other times she was saying oh great i'm on my way
first crucify me and then take me so he pierced my hands and feet
through with nails and while doing this to my highest sorrow he disappeared i
found myself inside of me okay
oh i'm still here she said how many times you've done this to me my dear
Jesus i want to give you two Corinthians five versus one to ten for that
indeed you have a special art of being able to do it
and you make me believe that i must die so i laugh at the world at the pains and i
even laugh at you because the time of our being
separated is ended that's why she'd laugh and there will be no more
intervals of separation but as soon as the laughing begins
i found myself bound again with the shackles of the wall
of this fragile body forgetting that i had begun to laugh i continue with the
crying the moans and the size of my separation from you
our lord hurry for i feel compelled to come she wants so
badly to go to heaven but she has 47 more years
to go before she dies this is martyrdom so i want to leave it there for the
moment